ja ich begrüße alle zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer des philosophischen kanals das
philosophische jahrbuchs auf youtube und
heute wollen wir mal unseren leserinnen
und lesern das archiv erst mal das
philosophische jahrbuch vorstellen
auf dem es alle bisher von 1888 bis 2009
erschienenen texte frei öffentlich zu
recherchieren gibt und ich gebe gerade
mal dieses archiv frei also es ist ein
wirklich großer schatz der hier digital
gehoben werden kann wenn man mal schaut
man sieht hier alle jahrgänge 1988 bis
schauen sie einfach mal vorbei sie
finden auch hier ein suchformular musik
zum beispiel hier mal alles nachschauen
können was sie suchen wollen
sie finden hier in textsuche im kontext
der jeweiligen begriff also das ist eine
gute möglichkeit auch philosophie
geschichte des neunzehnten und
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts zu betreiben
unten im videotext der beschreibung
mache ich den link zu diesem zu diesem
archiv so als nächstes möchte ich kurz
eine andere seite vorstellen nämlich die
seite des philosophischen jahrbuchs auf
der seite des herder und alba vermag
sind auch diese seite hat viel zu bieten
hier findet man jetzt das aktuelle heft
digital zugänglich und ganz besonders
möchte ich hervorheben die aktuelle
jahrbuch kontrovers sind zu luciano
flori dies im initiativ aufsatz der hier
auch sehr lobenswert ich finde gruppen
access angeboten wird und hier direkt
gelesen werden kann er kann auch hier
als pdf-datei heruntergeladen werden und
als word-dokument exportiert werden und
auch hier stelle ich den link direkt zu
diesem text
die beschreibung hinein so jetzt habe
ich genug gesagt als redakteur des
vesuvs möchte ich jetzt weitergeben an
mahlzeit stumpf vom alba verlag der sich
jetzt auch kurz vorstellte
ja ich erwarte ein sturm kann alba
verlag und ich bin die digitalen
projekte in der wissenschaft unseres
altehrwürdigen philosophischen verlages
ist und ständig kommen wir haben uns
vorgenommen den verlag ein bisschen in
die zukunft zu führen mit einem kleinen
aber ich finde sehr sehr stunden schritt
nämlich im schritt diesen aufsatz von
newey die open access zu stellen für den
zugänglich zu machen und das ist ja ein
schöner zusammenhang dass es sich dabei
gleich noch um einen aussätzigen
digitalisierung handelt mehr für das
inhaltliche zuständig ist der neben ihr
sitzende kollege dr martin henne den
händen leicht vorstellen kann
und der dann sozusagen das inhaltlich
vermindert ja hallo zu sagen also die
zuschauer des youtube kanals mein name
ist wie man ist und gesagt hat schon
hatte ich bin seit anfang des jahres
lektor im verlag alba und werden 2021
die programmleitung ist für sophie als
würdigen philosophie verweist übernehmen
und die neue jahrbuch kontrovers
das ist wirklich für den verlag sowohl
für den verlags also für die social
community endlich mal eine große chance
und der verlosung steht inhalte einer
breiteren öffentlichkeit zugänglich zu
machen um diskussionen anzuregen und
überhaupt auf die sichtbarkeit des
philosophischen jahr bewusst
man kann sagen dass eines unserer
flaggschiffe im verlag die sichtbarkeit
des profils zu erhöhen
endlich kann man ab und zu schon einmal
hatte war der aufschlag aus holz von
flori ist sehr vielgestaltig sehr
inhaltsreich mit sehr viel perspektive
auch im kontext von digitalisierung
künstlicher intelligenz und
informationsgesellschaft starke
politische implikation er wirft viele
fragen auf was natürlich sehr gute sehr
gute möglichkeit ist um diskutanten auf
diese fragen zu sagen kann zu setzen
das wird dann denke ich mal auch im lauf
der zeit auch in vielen leserinnen und
leser man so sichtbar in die darauf
folgende nummern des philosophischen die
handlungs verscheiden wo eben
renommierte illusion finden und
philosophen unter anderem markus gabriel
theermann denke ich mal ganz gut kennt
der community auf diesem aufsatz und die
inhalte dieses aufsatzes eingehen und
den zitiert darauf replizieren
wir freuen uns sehr auch in diese
gesellschaft ist politisch sehr
relevante debatte warum dann
philosophischer als personal zu führen
dann freuen wir uns sehr dass uns dieses
medium gefunden haben und auch weitere
folgen und so wirklich sehr dankbar dass
wir sozusagen von vielen seiten mit
diesen wind bekommen und wochen ist das
nachfolgeformat verändert ja vielen dank
von mir an alle zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer kann ich schon sagen unten
nochmal ein video allerdings zu dem text
den zeiten
wir werden jetzt auf diesem kanal in
zukunft weitere videos drehen wir werden
die jeweiligen hefte ft nannte
vorstellen und vielleicht werden wir
sogar auch die gelegenheit haben
einzelne autorin oder autoren hier auch
zur videos interviews zu gewinnen die
dann eben auch veröffentlicht werden
können also bleiben sie auf dem kanal
schauen sie doch mal vorbei
wir wollen hier das philosophische
jahrbuch auch die digitale gegenwart
hier überholen und natürlich auch auf
youtube vor ort
vielen dank fürs zu schaffen